le 29 octobre 1999 après jésus-christ
c'est à dire aujourd'hui astérix fête
ses 40 ans l'irréductible petit gaulois
est en effet apparu pour la première
fois le 29 octobre 59 dans le tout
premier numéro du journal pilote
créé par goscinny et uderzo astérix est
aujourd'hui traduit en 85 langue
miracles de la bd en 40 ans de carrière
astérix obélix et idéfix n'ont pas pris
une seule ride
sabine gornik jean christophe duclos en
40 ans cette main là on a croqué des
milliers de petits gaulois ténu à
moustache et casques et les 290 millions
d'albums vendus par toutatis qui aurait
pu se douter le jour de la naissance
d'astérix dans le journal pilote de
pareil succès à quartz et papa goscinny
le scénariste et uderzo sont tombé dans
la potion magique quand il était petit
ils sont fous ces romains
or les maldives ont fait un antihéros
bon alors géré dessiner un petit
personnage comme il le voulait et j'ai
dessiné à côté lui un bonhomme plutôt
costaud encore une fois sachant pas quoi
lui faire faire je lui ai mis un mail
hier sur le dos parce qu'il se trouvait
en bretagne
et puis rené tout de suite a senti que
ce personnage pourrait faire à faire
valoir et sanguinaire toute attitude il
nous protège prenez des gaulois forte
tête
une armée de romain ajoutez-y des
bagarres des sangliers de la cervoise
saupoudrait d'esprit gaulois et vous
comprendrez pourquoi dans la france des
années 60 envahi paris super héros
américain ces irréductibles ont vite
conquis le coeur des français
maintenant je connais pas bien connaître
un petit peu votre corps
explique c'est un peu tout le monde
on s'est amusé à jouer le tempérament du
français moyen
tous vont un peu alors sachant pas
voyager critiquant tout lorsqu'il se
passe à l'extérieur et quand il essaie
lui critique ans qui a fait lui c'est le
truc classique assez gueulard en ce qui
concerne la bonne bouffe assez
dans la rhétorique ainsi de suite depuis
l'entreprise astérix est devenue un
empire qui pèse son poids de sesterces
les produits dérivés sont légion un parc
d'attractions à son nom et dessin animé
un long métrage à succès et 1 30 minimes
album en préparation
bref du pain sur la planche à dessin
pour le papa d'astérix
si le ciel ne lui tombe pas sur la tête
et c'est la fin de cette année